terry mugler has died he was 73 years
old
[Music]
the iconic french fashion designer and
perfume creator's death was announced on
sunday with a message on his instagram
account alongside this image of a black
square
the caption reads quote we are
devastated to announce the passing of mr
manfred terry mugler on sunday january
23 2022 may his soul rest in peace et
has reached out to mugler's reps for
comment
tributes are pouring in from the fashion
community and celebrities alike
diana ross shared this pic to twitter
writing quote i will miss you terry
muglier this was a wonderful time in our
lives kourtney kardashian posted this
pic to her instagram story alongside the
kardashian family photo she wrote quote
all in muglier adding a broken heart
emoji
born manfred terry mugler he gained
international recognition in the 80s and
90s terry became a staple on the fashion
runway and a gochu designer for the red
carpet
dressing celebs like cindy crawford iman
and tyra banks he officially retired
from fashion in the early 2000s but
terry continued helping stars with their
ensembles this included beyonce robin
wright and megan fox
[Music]
in the recent years cardi b has made a
splash at the 2019 grammy awards thanks
to terry the rapper wore a clamshell
inspired dress from his 1995 collection
a few months later kim kardashian won
fashion's biggest night of the year
terry provided kim with a body hugging
nude mini dress now considered one of
the met gala's most memorable looks
you